okay so the topic of this video is going
to be chromosomes so let's go ahead and
get started
so this slideshow actually has a bit of
a story to it hello my name is Norma I'm
about four months pregnant I'm scheduled
for an ultrasound procedure today please
join me
here's Norma undergoing the ultrasound
and the doctor says you know during the
ultrasound procedure an image of the
baby is scanned and viewed on this
monitor
this process is non-invasive as only
sound waves are used it's similar to how
sonar is used to map the ocean floor
Norma I'm seeing something that concerns
me a little bit I think we should
perform another test called a karyotype
this test can provide more answers
oh no is the problem serious
it's hard to know I'd like to examine
the baby's chromosomes to get more
information
well what are chromosomes
so chromosomes are movable units of
tightly coiled DNA and proteins when you
look in the picture you can see a double
helix a DNA molecule but it's coiling up
and coiling up into this blue shaped
object labeled a chromosome which is
also kind of in the the shape of the
letter X right here so this is a
chromosome a movable unit of DNA and
proteins
chromosomes tend to form when cells
divide when cells divide through either
mitosis or meiosis they form chromosomes
right here we see the the chromosomes
are forming
now when cells divide and continue
through mitosis and meiosis the
chromosomes will be equally split
between the new cells so right here we
can see the chromosomes are separating
and then by the end 50 percent of the
chromosomes will be in the cell to the
left and 50 of the chromosomes in the
cell to the right
but chromosomes are movable units of DNA
and if we examine a chromosome
a little more closely we can see it's
got a couple parts to it we have what
are known as the chromatids these are
the left sides and the right sides
chromatids are are identical their exact
duplicates of one another so the genetic
material in the left chromatid is a
duplication of the genetic material on
the right chromatid
notice they join at this little location
here not always in the middle but right
here in this picture it's kind of more
towards the middle known as the central
mirror this is a the location where the
left and right chromatids tend to join
with one another
so the doctor says I'd like to examine
the baby's chromosomes to see if they
appear normal
well how can you examine the baby's
chromosomes he she isn't even born yet
well first I'd like to perform an
amniocentesis procedure
I'm going to insert this needle into the
womb this needle right here into the
womb and suck up some of the fluid that
surrounds the baby
there are cells from the baby that are
floating in this fluid
and once I suck up the cells we can
examine the chromosomes of this baby for
examination
so now that I have the fetal cells we're
going to karyotype them
well what's a karyotype
so karyotype is a picture of an
individual's chromosomes here is a
normal karyotype from a person
and karyotypes are useful because they
help to identify any chromosome
abnormalities that might be present
normally a human should contain 23 pairs
of chromosomes
for instance here's a pair of chromosome
number fours see there's a chromosome on
the left and there's a chromosome on the
right so they're arranged in pairs
here's chromosome pair number nine
there's two of them one chromosome on
the left and one chromosome on the right
here's chromosome 13. there's a pair of
them
now when you look at this picture right
here here's a karyotype showing an
abnormality notice how this person has
three chromosome 21s this is a
chromosome condition known as trisomy 21
you've probably heard it more commonly
called Down syndrome if a person is born
with three chromosome 21s this is a
diagnosis of down syndrome
notice this karyotype right here this is
a karyotype of a person with Trisomy 13
also known as patau's syndrome so a
karyotype can identify if there is an
abnormality
and in this karyotype the abnormality is
known as monosomi X they only have one X
chromosome they should have two X
chromosomes this condition is also
called Turner's syndrome so by examining
a person's chromosomes a certain perhaps
a diagnosis can be made if there's an
abnormality
so here's our normal karyotype again
and so a normal human should have 23
pairs of chromosomes the first 22 pairs
these right here are known as autosomes
autosomes are defined as the non-sex
chromosomes there's no genes on these
chromosomes that are going to influence
one's gender male or female sex
now when you look at the arrangement of
the autosomes you'll notice that the
biggest chromosome is chromosome number
one and they progressively get a little
smaller this is how they've been
identified chromosome one two three
obviously the chromosomes are not
numbered when they're inside of our
cells but we have arranged them from
basically biggest to smallest
and what about the other pair of
chromosomes these right here are known
as the sex chromosomes pair number 23.
and these sex chromosomes these do
contain genes that will influence
whether a person is male or female
and in this case right here this is
actually a male right here because of
the X and Y chromosome combination
but in this picture right here we see a
karyotype showing a female the X in X
chromosome combination
so if I put these two karyotypes side by
side and ask you which karyotype is male
which karyotype is female
I hope you see the one on the left is
male the one on the right is female the
female has the XX combination the male
has the X Y combination
so back to the story for a moment now
that we have cells from amniocentesis
let's examine the baby's chromosomes
so here are the chromosomes underneath
the microscope these chromosomes were
taken from cells obtained by
amniocentesis
naturally they're not arranged in neat
orderly rows when they're inside the
cell
the chromosomes have been stained for
better viewing and then photographed
and now that we have a paper picture of
the chromosomes I can cut them out one
at a time and match them together
we'll arrange the autosomes in order
from longest to shortest
enormouses I noticed that the
chromosomes are arranged in pairs is
that significant
that's because we are looking at
chromosomes from a diploid cell
Norma says well what are diploid cells
so diploid cells are cells with paired
chromosomes if you notice there's a pair
of chromosome 20s one on the left and
one on the right a pair of chromosome
nines a pair of chromosome 22s all the
chromosomes are paired
diploid cells therefore will contain the
full set of chromosomes common to a
species and in humans there are 23 pairs
of chromosomes so the human diploid
number is 46 total chromosomes
but other species might be different
this is the karyotype taken from a
diploid cell of a rat what is the
diploid chromosome number for rats you
can see there are 21 total pairs of
chromosomes 21 pairs would be a total
number of 42 chromosomes
in this karyotype this is a karyotype
taken from the diploid cells of a
gorilla what is the diploid chromosome
number for gorillas well gorillas have
24 pairs of chromosomes so their diploid
number is 48.
so diploid cells are created through the
process of mitosis and here's a picture
of the stages so when a cell begins
mitosis it actually is already diploid
and by the end will remain diploid so
mitosis maintains the same amount of
genetic material at the start versus the
end very different than meiosis which
we'll talk about briefly in a little bit
so examples of diploid cells are what
are called somatic cells and these are
the non-sex cells these are cells of the
body not involved in reproduction cells
like blood cells muscle cells bone cells
skin cells nerve cells heart cells the
vast majority of the body falls in the
category of diploid somatic cells
so back to the story here for a moment
we inherit our chromosomes from our
mother and father that's why we should
have two of every chromosome well are
all the cells in my body diploid
no some cells are haploid well then what
are haploid cells
so haploid cells are cells with single
or unpaired chromosomes look at the
picture there's only one chromosome 11
not two one chromosome 18 not two if I
put it side by side with a diploid
karyotype from earlier you should see
the diploid chromosomes are paired and
the haploid chromosomes are singles so
haploid cells contain only half the
total number of chromosomes and in
humans that would be 23 chromosomes so
the human diploid number is 46 but half
of 46 is haploid which would be 23.
meiosis is the process that creates
haploid cells so when a cell goes
through meiosis it'll actually start
diploid but through the actions of
meiosis become haploid so during meiosis
the chromosome number is reduced by 50
percent that's something we'll learn
later on when we talk about meiosis
so what kind of cells are haploid cells
these are the gametes the male gamete
would be sperm cells and the female
gamete would be egg cells so gametes are
the sex cells these are the cells
involved in reproduction now in plants
pollen is the male equivalent to sperm
cells so pollen sperm and egg cells are
examples of gametes
oh I get it says Norma a male sperm cell
has 23 chromosomes a female egg cell has
23 chromosomes sex brings the egg and
sperm together and when they combine
they create a cell with 46 total
chromosomes precisely a fertilized egg
is called a zygote it is the first cell
of a new human
I have good news there doesn't seem to
be any chromosome abnormalities with
your baby would you like to know the sex
of the baby
or from what you said earlier I think I
know the baby has the XY chromosome
combination it's a boy
that is correct we'll schedule another
ultrasound procedure in a few weeks to
continue to monitor your baby's
development thank you for your help
today
so let's practice some of the vocabulary
we saw throughout the slideshow here's
the rat karyotype from before and here's
some 10 questions right here pause the
video I'm going to go over the answers
in three two one
number one what is the sex of the Rat
used to make this karyotype you can see
the XX chromosome combination I hope you
said female now all the other questions
are talking about how many chromosomes
there's going to be notice in the
karyotype rats have 21 pairs of
chromosomes well if you have 21 pairs of
shoes that would be 42 shoes so the
diploid number of rats is going to be 42
and haploid means half half of 42 is 21.
so you're going to see the numbers 42
and 21 in questions 2 through 10.
question number two how many chromosomes
can be found in somatic cells well
somatic cells are diploid so they would
have 42. how many chromosomes in a skin
cell well a skin cell is a somatic cell
which we just said our diploid 42. how
many chromosomes are in a gamete cell
gamete cells are haploid that would be
21. and we already said the Gap the
diploid number is 42. for number six how
many chromosomes in a sperm cell a sperm
cell is an example of a haploid gamete
which would be 21. how many chromosomes
in a blood cell blood cells are somatic
and somatics are diploid which is 42 and
we already said haploid is 21. number
nine how many chromosomes in a Cell made
by mitosis well cells made by mitosis
are diploid which would be 42. and how
many chromosomes in a zygote cell well
the zygote is when a sperminate combined
21 chromosomes in a sperm combines with
21 chromosomes in an egg to make a
zygote with 42 chromosomes
so as I wrap up this video here's a
practice quiz that you can try to to
check your understanding I hope you
found this video helpful thanks for
watching everyone